vous avez finalisé plus de contrats de
bail que n'importe quelle autre équipe
c'est quoi le truc j'ai grandi dans un
village de vernier est au d autres
acteurs mais on sait nous il y avait une
usine caterpillar
ils ont fermé quand j'entrais en fac et
toutes mes illusions sur la petite vie
de fermier sans souci ni volé en éclats
je leur offre le seul moyen de rebondir
je vous l'annoncerai n'y résiste bien
il n'y croit pas on vient juste de
sortir de la ville et on sera dans le
kentucky
tu sors de n'importe quelle ville et une
croix dans le capte qui c'est toi la
propriété pourquoi tu fait tout le
boulot alors une housse signé ce contrat
et ça nous donne le droit de forer sur
le terme y à beaucoup d'argent derrière
oui beaucoup combien vous croyais je ne
vois aucune raison pour qu'il n'y ait
pas une bonne école chez vous ça peut
rapporter combien vous serez
millionnaire ça fait dur c'est trop
facile
les recherches ont donné quelque chose
sur la présence d'écolo dans coin non
allez je me environ 40 marié marketing
deux enfants 38 serveuse deux jours
comme garde la nuit
mais pour être une chanteuse qui suit un
titre i maintenant sept mois que je
parlais salut tout le monde je suis là
parce que notre ferme n'existe plus
intérêts mort plus rien de plus de dents
si c'est arrivé à ma famille ça peut
aussi arriver à la vôtre
la ville va procéder à un vote trois
semaines et c'est tout se retrouver
je sais tout ce que vous dit tu crois
que tu sera à la hauteur pour te battre
oh oui
cette vie c'est mort vous le savez était
au cameroun a la bonne idée de se marrer
c'est pas les hectares qui conseille les
gens c'est pour ça qu'on lui que tu
comprends vous n'avez aucune chance
d'obtenir ce que vous attendez moi j'ai
un peu de style
j'aurais préféré que vos talents soient
au service de notre groupe
une compagnie qui pèse d'affilée duceppe
cours mais capable tu fais toi t'es sûr